okay we're here with the iconic Susan
Sarandon and you've been in so many
iconic movies would it be possible to
get a fun fact at detail a morsel a
behind the scenes look yes I'm ready
this is behind the scenes
shoot Witches of Eastwick I was actually
cast in Cher's part and when I showed up
they had given my part to share I then
didn't have any wardrobe she gave me the
gold dress and the red wig
laughs
Bull Durham Bull Durham the studio again
did not want me and um I auditioned I
was living in Italy I had a one and a
half year old child I flew myself in
again swallowing my ego read the entire
script with Kevin got on a plane went
back to this deserted place in Italy and
then like three days later they knocked
on my door because I didn't have a phone
and they said you have to go back
because you got the movie oh and then
you met your husband I did we never got
married but yes we had many children in
real estate together
foreign
[Applause]
cat spin was great and whenever I had
big party she was the first one that
came back the next morning to help me
clean up oh wow Catherine den of folks
oh my God the one and only Catherine
denove helps you clean up after parties
I know thank you I'm satisfied okay
because I didn't have children at that
time so I did have parties oh I know I
used to have the best parties in the
world remember who we were I know we'll
get I'll get back there Thelma and
Louise
did you know when you were making it
no because I don't know if you remember
but when it came out a lot of people
were very offended uh by Thelma Louise
how so it condoned suicide it it
encourages women to be violent all the
things that happen in every other movie
with a male lead that nobody even looked
twice at suddenly we were doing Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid and
everybody was getting
they just were disturbed by women taking
their own power and they had to find a
reason and really it's about friendship
and it's about it's kind of romantic I
think it's a love story it's a love
story absolutely I was so in awe also I
love love stories of the platonic nature
because sometimes like the sex of it
convolutes like I loved Paper Moon and
midnight run and Planes Trains and
Automobiles and all these you know
movies that were not the romantic love
it just let me Focus deeper on love
itself because it's the bravest thing
you can do is to be open to another
person right
foreign
[Laughter]
it's so true but that movie also touches
on why it's so hard to trust you know
some of the men are very black and white
for what they do wrong and what they
don't and then you have Brad Pitt who's
so hot and shirtless and who wouldn't go
for it but then he rips her off and
you're like I didn't see that
he was so good when I saw the scenes
um where he taunts the husband and
everything that's when I thought this
guy's really special I like your wife
[Laughter]
[Music]
your Academy Award Dead Man Walking
Dead Man Walking I had read the book and
I met with sister Helen I was doing the
client at the time and she didn't know
which one
she knew I was in Tamil movie she didn't
know which one I was
and she gave me the book and the rights
to it on a handshake during a fabulous
crawfish dinner on the basis also of
Amnesty International vouching for me
because of my some of my political work
so right there we had this transaction
Tim didn't move on it for like a year
and I finally had a meltdown the middle
of Seventh Avenue and said if you're not
going to do this
I'm going to take it to somebody else
and then he said all right all right
I'll try and he wrote a brilliant script
and made a brilliant I made a brilliant
movie
tomorrow which one would it be
Bull Durham I think would be the most
fun well because you have two hot men
too high thank you
[Applause]
I told you I told you gonna be too late
I love you
[Music]